passe encore majeur mais déjà titulaires
d'une carte de presse en première au
lycée emilie de breteuil ses élèves sont
en pleine conférence de rédaction
cinq amis qui ont créé leur propre
journal la gazette des mines
sané pendant les vacances dernière
pendant une petite période d'ennuis et
donc du coup avec guillaume et un camion
s'est dit qu'on allait créer le journal
du lycée parce qu'on aime beaucoup
journalisme et s'exprimer sur tout et
donc du coup en septembre on a commencé
à écrire et on a sorti le premier numéro
en octobre je crois on fait toujours une
interview une grande interview donc pour
le premier numéro c'est une interview
dur au travers et occupèrent de youtube
à la politique
pour leur deuxième numéro en novembre
les adolescents ont questionné benoît
hamon et jean frédéric poisson
aujourd'hui ils finalisent leur
quatrième édition
au programme une quinzaine de pages sur
l'actualité avec un article sur les
violences policières
mais aussi culture avec de la poésie moi
j'écris des poèmes choisi un thème et à
partir de ce thème là j'essaie d'écrire
ce qui me vient à l'esprit en fait
j'essaie de faire passer un message à
travers mes poèmes avec le 8 mars comme
stage où la femme j'ai écrit deux poèmes
sur la femme donc j'essaye en fait de
m'inspirer de mon quotidien ou
d'événements qui me marque ou qui touche
mon entourage pour effectuer les
recherches de la rubrique actualités
direction les sites des grands médias
mais les apprentis journalistes n'ont
aucune envie de copier leurs objectifs
un journal par des jeunes pour des
jeunes on veut pas rentrer et non plus
dans les gros gros sujet parce que c'est
pas notre rôle est plus on n'est pas
qualifié pour ça mais on dire quelques
mots ce important puis rester simple
dans l'écriture est pas se prendre la
tête
vraiment pas je pense que c'est
important d'informer les jeunes qui
n'ont pas forcément l'envi de de
s'informer et comme dans chaque
rédaction il y a un directeur de
publication ils m'ont présenté
le sommaire est donc
donc j'ai donné mon accord il me demande
si je suis d'accord pour des interviews
pour des sujets d'actualité et donc en
fonction je leur donne mon accord mais
en général c'est le cas puisque ce sont
vraiment des élèves très sérieux après
validation ultime étape l'impression le
quatrième numéro sera tiré à une
centaine d'exemplaires disponibles au
lycée la gazette des milliers est
également à retrouver sur internet sur
le site de l'établissement